I have a voicemail today that is it's an important
issue that for some reason people think I'm
unwilling to address.
I'm very willing to address it.
Our voicemail number is two one nine two David
Pakman.
And this has to do with covid deaths.
Take a listen to this.
Hey, David Stroman, the intellectual here,
so I've got a question for you.
New Jersey, New York and Massachusetts had
the highest death rate per capita from covid-19,
right, yet they had pretty restrictive measures
like and all that.
Yeah, Florida.
Was pretty low on that list.
I wonder why are the scientists there is a
science actually is that accurate?
It seems like it's not.
I'd like to hear your thoughts.
Yeah.
This has nothing to do with science being
or not being accurate.
So as a the argument from troll man, the anti
intellectual is you've got these blue states,
blue states claim to be better uncovered.
But New York, New Jersey and Massachusetts
have some of the highest death rates per capita.
What's the explanation?
Well, you know, the first thing is you have
to think, is there a counterexample?
Well, yeah, Vermont and Maine are very blue
states and they have some of the lowest death
rates per capita.
This goes back to, you know, look at death
rates per capita in the last six months and
you see a very different picture.
And unfortunately, some of the best connected
places that have both lots of conferences
and and people that come from all over the
world for meetings and direct flights to the
early sources of the virus got hit the hardest
in deaths per capita because they had some
of the earliest outbreaks before we were better
at treating, isolating and containing the
coronavirus.
The perfect examples are Boston, where one
of the earliest kind of spreader events was
a conference that included people from Asia
and Europe in Boston that became sort of an
early spreader event and seeded the virus
in the Boston area, New York and Boston, with
direct flights to, you know, Italy, multiple
cities in China, France, Germany.
You know, the places where the virus came
to the U.S. from.
You had months of flights, nonstop flights
back and forth from Boston, almost the exact
same thing with New York and New Jersey, New
York with JFK Airport, New Jersey, just over
the bridge, what is it, nine miles from from
Manhattan with Newark Airport, nonstop flights
everywhere and huge conferences, et cetera.
So there is really no set rule.
Mississippi has one of the highest per capita
death rates.
It's not because Mississippi has nonstop flights
all over the world to places that were early
covid infected places.
Mississippi is high because they didn't do
a damn thing.
Different places have different explanations.
Now, the Massachusetts death rate, for example,
is tiny.
I believe that three people died on Saturday
and eight people died on Sunday.
Extremely low death rate now unlucky New York,
New Jersey, Massachusetts, to have been hit
early with almost uncontrolled spread with
nonstop flights to the hot spots.
So, you know, there's no one one stop shop
answer.
If anybody's looking for a one stop shop answer,
there really isn't one.
But it is interesting to look at per capita
death in case rates over the last six months
rather than at the very beginning when we
knew very little.
Great bonus show for today for you.
Today, we will talk about what's going on
with prison inmates and covid release some
maybe disturbing things.
We will talk about the flop of a White Lives
Matter rally.
And we will talk about the Chinese covid vaccine,
which seems to have low efficacy.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show get instant access by becoming a member
at Join Pakman Dotcom.